it's so fun
when our world is threatened
one team
launch
does he say lunch uh no I said launch
Ed
[Music]
it's giving off some kind of energy
I didn't do it
no way this September I think we got
super powers
and that's why I wear a hard hat
[Music]
look at your paws
now the clumsy pup shoots Fireballs out
of his paws
breed of Heroes
are real hits the big screen
ourselves how about the PAW Patrol but
more but just a little bit extra
how about
the mighty pups
those would be my superpowers
I'm gonna take them one by one
oh my goodness I could talk
give me that
it's showtime
he looks different than I remember
you go up against one of us
you go up against all of us
now that we're super I'm never gonna get
to sleep well you're probably more tired
than you
oh you've got to be kidding me
foreign
[Music]